hmm welcome to this video playing our
scene from the from the u.s. in a 15
minute game can have really big rating
difference started with the modern
defends g6 yeah but here here it is
really difficult to to to not transpose
to the King's Indian I don't really like
a5 that much even the trade only 5 is
not so great
and the knight c6 d5 is just better for
white okay let's go to the Kings Indian
97 is interesting I think this is a bit
better than the other two but anyway the
King's Indian is the way to go here
Bishop g5 is a bit unusual at that's
very committal giving away the bishop so
early
yeah I'm considering to take with the
pawn it's a it looks a bit strange maybe
but it is interesting intending to play
f5 quickly and then open up the position
after Bishop takes its might
yeah it's both interesting bishop takes
is also not bad at all yeah let's do
that come on taking with the bonus so um
also interesting interesting okay I'd
like to be used them the dark square so
I need to attack the center with c5 or
a5 and if I have yeah I didn't really
want it wasn't my idea to trade Queens
Queen a five was the what's my plan so
now yeah yeah pawn takes is not so bad
it gives some some other interesting
ideas getting quickly on the default is
what I'm talking about yeah it's
probably both good the Queen takes is
also not bad yeah yes this 92 we played
really quickly is it Scarlett's bit of a
clocked up development how does him
coordinate that maybe g3 Bishop g2
yeah ninety-fourth 2022 just runs into
94 I see if is here thinking about long
castling here that looks a bit we yet
but maybe
yeah I'm threatening 94 here maybe you
need to guess along
night before maybe but it is a threat
isn't it he must go to see one I believe
almost yeah let's let's move that why
does he do now
okay maybe disree but yeah I the night
b3 he was an additional idea so he
couldn't go Queen d2 for example so what
now should five I'm not really he might
do Knight d5 that that's not not really
convenient
okay I I want to control d5 it looks a
bit strange for this bishop but it it
can go to c6
so just Bishop c6 yeah no that's okay
so I have from two bishops one on c6 one
on f6 and I have the d4 square that's a
very very comfortable position
yeah he wants to trade yeah not I'm not
100% sure what's the best way to to play
this castling short I mean age six hangs
not so great I can't cast a long I mean
it's a bit uncommon in the sinner Kings
Indian type of position but why not
really maybe yes Queen f4 attacking the
bishop and the ticking of seven okay I'm
not sure that it was great but I hadn't
really considered it before okay so
maybe you look at these seven what
taking first yeah okay I mean I am I
always have prospects in the endgame I
don't I don't need to do anything fancy
just trading is not not bad okay
Queen before increasing the pressure
here December this is also good doubling
on the D file and that covers f7 so if
he goes Queen f4 I just take B - yeah
that's very comfortable it's got a bed
Bishop on d3 I have two bishops a
weakness on deform so a very very good
position
uh-huh before maybe yeah that's but I
can take a take a one okay so I can I
don't need to fear before no fear for
before no no fear about okay anyway this
looks really shaky I can enter here Jack
Queen here you check that looks really
really nice
yeah King edge to us is forced and what
now Bishop e5 yeah he can go where for
it's not very attractive move but it's
playable maybe I should just take f2 and
threaten there should be five check yeah
that's probably the best one there
should be five is a really big threat
and move like Queen f4 I can just trade
and play Bishop e5 that's really
disastrous yeah it's there something
better than what I just what I just
mentioned and they are probably not King
g3 this g v g3 that Bishop d2 check
check and eat
efore and b2 are hanging yeah this even
this crossfire of the bishops check
there's no mate though maybe here and
look H - yeah but okay let's let's keep
it simple this is very easy attacking
the rook it has no square only a2 and
then push up default check wins the rook
he cannot attack any of my pieces so
there's some
there's not much to calculate
let's see yeah okay I can just I just
take it
Bishop d4 check it's not bad
check
yeah rook age one mate and that's hard
to prevent only with and not even not
even with with a knight move checkmate
yeah but nevertheless this was an
instructive game of course it's a very
substantial mismatch of rating but it
was still a instructive because he
committed some some positional errors
it starts with Bishop f6 really this is
already already a mistake you shouldn't
give up this bishop so early especially
in this structure where you already
committed to we already committed to
these three pawn moves the thing is that
the the weakest spot in the Kings Indian
is the d4 square for white it is as you
can see unprotected by a pawn due to the
advance in the center and the check that
black plays in the center in the normal
lines let's say just for example if
white plays a normal kind of line then
black is playing a 5-2 a tech deform or
c5 to attack d4 it's always around the
c-4 Square and it's about forcing a
commitment to make this diagonal better
or to gain a pawn play on the Kings side
like that this allows us later
f5 advance to to get play what if you
look at the typical benoni structure
white was provoked to move the D pawn so
that this is a strong diagonal or T
deaths he placed the horns like that and
now gave up this Bishop yeah basically
for free and now a look at this I
already have pressure against this pawn
it's an open diagonal
and that will be attacked with C 596 and
not with this but with C 596 I have
enormous pressure on this pawn and it
would be difficult for him not to move
it at some point if we look what he did
he played Age 3 which is maybe because
of that this would also increase the
pressure on d4 with the pin so h3 is
this makes and make some sense but now
look at this c5 how does he keep this
the center now it's it's tricky I mean
this is just an amazing position for
black and the dark squares are really
really weakened this is the the problem
with giving up the bishop you you weaken
the color complex of the bishops color
here the dark squares and these are the
sensitive squares if white loses the or
gives up the light squared bishop it's
usually not not such a problem as the
light squares are not the squares where
black initiates his play the king's
engine is typical dark-squared focused
opening and giving up the dark squared
bishop form the knight is usually not a
good idea c5 and now he took their hits
it's debatable but what to do maybe this
is relatively best I don't know after
that I already have a have a convenient
choice I mean I could also take and take
which is slightly better for black
simply because of the pawns but this
this pawn now on c3 it does an important
job to cover especially to big d4 square
this is why I didn't want to do that
it's the nice position for black this is
a very bad piece but ok I didn't want to
do that I wanted to keep the the dark
square some dark to invisible life and
here I think he really should go Queen
d2
probably it's not not nice but I think
it's better than this this really
hampers young development and he had a
good good alternative I also could take
here but I wasn't 100% convinced that
this is the right way to play as this
has the additional idea to quickly get
something on the D file and of course
establishing a pawn on on c5 means that
I have pong control over the victim for
square plate Quincy - yeah and this runs
in 290 formerly yeah and here he is
interesting I mean you can also try
technical things yeah like Bishop g5 to
threaten to take and win material and
it's not so easy to to play against that
as there's also 'if I've threatened so
wide probably needs to do a very ugly
move like g3 which even exhaust this one
yeah Bishop g5 was even stronger than my
move I played a purely positional move
increasing control in the center g5 is
now covered and I control all the vital
square cm the 92 and long castles yeah
and it's very very difficult to black
therefore white - to get a decent game
this is means that I was thinking about
briefly but I can always take him and
now he does not really have a good move
I can even take
with the Buddha good position but it was
better than what he got he played and
think this is this is now getting very
very difficult I mean this this wasn't
really helping but what do you play I'm
attacking this this Bishop b2 as
attacked the computer is already giving
black five pawns so there is a very
substantial material gain just around
the corner cha-cha and this is this is
some very very quick win the the point
is what what what's always what to
remember is that in a Kings Indian
structure where white already has played
those pawns giving up the dark squared
Bishop is not a good idea it's almost in
general not a good idea
but it's not so bad for it just for
comparison's sake if you let's say for
example I would play this move just just
to show a difference if I could let's
like let's play like this and now this I
would still play Bishop h4 here but if
white would take here just for some
argument's sake this is not so bad if in
comparison to the other position in the
game as now the e3 pawn controls deform
this is far less of a problem for white
then then the game continuation here I
can build up some pressure on d4 but
it's not so easy for me to provoke him
to move it more for example if I would
play c5 at some point then for example
this is this type of capture regardless
of the castling rights but just just
think in structures it's not so terrible
as in the game as the pawn on e3 always
controls this therefore it moves like
that would be would be atrocious yeah
just giving up this square this is
exactly the structure that we got in the
game
all right I hope you liked some of the
position of motifs yeah I think it's
instructive how to play on the dark
squares thanks for watching